reading lots of Korean also I get you're
trying to tell a year mm audience how
big comic books are and everything but
is there any reason why you needed to
tell us the number of pages and
illustrations also I need a source on
all these statistics can someone call
that Wikipedia guy to put a citation
needed on this movie what happens in the
delivery did you drop them this doctor
apparently went to the school of making
things super dramatic instead of just
telling everyone what the problem is
they can't even fit the name of the
school under the sign it's so long and
drawn-out his arms and his legs are
broken really then what the book was
this earlier with the baby moving his
arms back and forth also a medical
diagnosis delivered as a sermon
hello everyone my name is n night
Shyamalan I am extremely clever with my
camera and won't someone notice me why
are we talking about me I'm afraid of
water David Dunn is the same weakness as
the aliens and signs why did this girl
choose to sit next to David when the two
seats in front of them seemed to be
wholly unoccupied how long you gonna be
in Philadelphia I'm married not for long
immediately after being rejected idiot
separated husband goes right back to
wearing the ring dude either the
marriage is salvageable or it isn't this
girl on the train should have no bearing
on the matter not this train cars seats
facing backwards how is this girl facing
the extra marital embarrassment that is
Bruce Willis right now
what's with the upside-down kids in this
movie this shot of David in the
background while the body in the
foreground gets bloodier by the second
this is some masterful shot between the
six-tenths in this movie I'm actually
not surprised at night keeps getting
work despite his failures this here is
some brilliant stuff man
a minutes worth of silent reflection
bullsh sure it's an unbroken shot the
shot is unbreakable but it's not like
fawn or anything awkward separated but
still in love with wife you didn't die
hug hey Dad you should love mom again
okay please did they leave it up to
David the lock up the church after the
memorial service where did everybody go
$40 um four-door sedan see I can play
this game too I checked you were right
you're never taking a sick day five
years no sick day I get it okay even if
David Dunn were somehow clueless to his
own and vulnerabilities there's no way
he'd work a job for five years and not
remember he hadn't taken a sick day to
the point where he needs to ask me a
note left with a secretary do you
remember me getting sick he can't even
remember ever getting sick in his life I
mean by 15 he'd be bragging to the other
kids about how he never gets sick by 25
he'd be like Bill Murray and Groundhog
Day doing everything he can to try to
get sick and by 35 he'd be selling his
blood to the CDC via the CIA
would not happen is this guy not getting
sick his entire life and not be noticing
it where is it on a bench across the
street yep I your mother left a present
for you you want a bench across the
street in 1974 West Philadelphia and I
still expect it to be there when you're
paranoid ass finds his way through the
fear and across the parking lot
Wow even wrapped in purple paper
screaming I am a present please open me
this gift somehow remain untouched until
a little mr. glass got here things are
constantly upside-down and symbolic and
in this movie but this camera move keeps
our view of the comic book upside down
for a bit until it decides now let's
look at this right-side up for once
making me wonder what the point of that
was other than they look cool they say
this one has a surprise ending thanks M
night for telegraphing the surprise
ending my kid's gonna go berserk once a
game please if Elijah has such standards
for the works of art in this place why
didn't he try to figure out this guy's
intentions in the first place you need
to go now I'm wondering how Elijah stays
in business he caters to people with
extremely specific tastes already and
now he's kicking this guy out for
wanting to give that drawing to his kid
I mean does he stay in business if he
sells just one of these the written this
place has got to be high his mom must
have bought him a few of those comic
books that currently sold for a hundred
and forty thousand dollars he must not
have to worry about money did you see a
little asian child with a blank
expression sitting outside in a
mechanical helicopter the shakes when
you put quarters in it
that's super racist we're by appointment
only Elijah who stuck his greeting card
on David's car and is hoping this guy
shows up isn't the least bit curious as
to who walked into his store I believe
comics our last link to an ancient way
of passing on history I know he's
supposed to be crazy and everything but
what exactly two comic books do to pass
on history exactly hieroglyphs actually
tell a history comic books tell the
story of mutant powers in most cases and
then get adapted into bullshit like
Suicide Squad if there is someone like
me in the world and I'm at one end of
the spectrum couldn't that be someone
else opposite of me at the other end
okay sure
Elijah's a crazy dude but I really don't
know what he expects someone to do once
he finds that unbreakable person hey
your bones break and mine don't let's be
friends it's time for me to focus during
the scene because I keep hearing James
Spader in my head deciphering these
glyphs behind samuel l.jackson here
just
don't take another sip of that water
well if it was poisoned game over I
guess I mean what are we protecting him
a problem at this point looking at this
newspaper I wonder why David isn't a
much bigger celebrity than he is surely
he'd be getting hit up for interviews
his face would be well known to everyone
and he'd be getting people bothering him
everywhere he goes but this guy still
lives and relative B's after this David
here's an only so that he can't complete
his flashback until later in the movie
when the audience needs a whammy reveal
he's kind of stuff out of line too bad
David can't be at all the entrances
during the time leading to kickoff is
this the only guy bringing a weapon into
the stadium today if so what a lucky
break there was this movie saying
there's only one entrance to the stadium
and if so where are all these people
walking around the line going and then
the guy leaves and David doesn't follow
him or anything maybe there really is
only one entrance to this place remember
how David told this guy in person to
start patting people down he didn't get
on the radio to do that so any number of
entrances where they aren't padding down
this guy can get in how'd you know that
guy you bumper was carrying a weapon
more to the point how lucky were you to
bump into that guy who had a weapon the
most unbelievable thing about this movie
is that Sam Jackson's character
magically spots the camouflage jacket
guy from earlier after a long time
between the ticket line and Elijah
leaving hold up a second do not shout
this is people you want to check for
handguns bad idea also then you spot him
outside the stadium in the parking lot
and now you're chasing him inside the
stadium the fuck is going on with
geography in the scene there's no thing
when he sees this after breaking 50
bones
he's Potter's cousin he's starting
cornerback jumping University you the
guy the agent was signing about at the
beginning of the movie before she died
in a train crash here right now how much
did you put on that were you asleep when
you put the weights on the father-son
bonding superpower discovering
weightlifting scene is so good have I
mentioned how brilliant M nights I was
early on in his career ah I know David
is a burgeoning superhero but despite
this the movie has him struggling to
lift 270 pounds but then they add more
weight and he suddenly blows that out of
the water either he's super strong and
this kind of weight doesn't affect him
at all or there is a limit which you
shouldn't reach yet just turn on some
lights Elijah right well isn't that
convenient for the story were telling
she's a physical therapist he's a guy in
need of physical therapy and all the gin
joints in all the towns in all the world
he walks into hurts
what part of David's body was injured
who said my husband's name was David you
see this makes it seem like Elijah is
super creepy and well yeah he kind of is
but it's not like he could control who
he got when he got sent to physical
therapy
I mean this
ripped is the villain here if you lied
you planned this somehow then he is the
most psychic mother I've ever seen
also dang em night we get it you like
the Bible David Joseph Elijah I'm
surprised you didn't name Robin Wright's
character Bathsheba I like how this drug
deal is what David decides to go after
and not the obviously abused child from
a few minutes ago
drugs are worse than child abuse which
means this movie was made by the DEA I
don't admire the restraint em Knight
puts in this movie I haven't seen one of
his usual cameo excuse me sir you step
out of line please it feels like the
stadium is the crime center of the world
why not always have pat downs when
people are coming in Metal Detectors I
mean man this college football team must
be like the 1980s Miami Hurricanes or
something to have so many outlaw fans
movie pulls a gotcha
proving David's visions wrong and making
him doubt himself when really is just an
excuse to pad the runtime and extra 20
minutes it appears that this middle
school is in session basically so why is
there a college football game going on
right now something that usually happens
on Saturdays and definitely only at
nights during weekdays I office was on
the other side of the building bang
scene about you lady just tell the story
about the drowning already old lady
remembers David thank God then tells him
a story about him almost drowning that
he entirely forgot and now he we used
that story to avoid his true calling but
I'm still more pissed that he somehow
forgot his own near drowning he's one of
the stupidest heroes ever I think you
still fuck because water who asked
questions like this don't you just say
are you scared of the water just what
the hell are you doing
yep that's right Joseph is so desperate
to prove his dad's a superhero he's
going to shoot him shoot him not cut him
with a knife or throw a glass at him or
any other still crazy but still more
sensible than a gun way to test that
theory Jesus Christ Joseph get your
together also a good job with gun safety
David you think twat and Friends listen
to each other they don't and they don't
shoot each other do they Audrey and no
shooting friends Joseph I can't tell if
this is supposed to be a moment of
levity or if it's terrible until then
Nick Deary the early years next to the
comics that would inspire him better not
be jacking off to the Japanese comics I
swear to God
dude you can see Elijah from here you
can clearly see he's in a wheelchair and
not jacking off and nowhere near
Japanese comics you racist look man I
didn't know you were enough bull you
knew there's no way you missed this guy
coming into your store Elijah is
addictive Comics comic store employees
and his own goddamn lick David is a
really tactile minded guy touching
humans gives him visions of what they've
done and touching a train now triggers
his final flashback which was a car
accident 25 years ago with
makes touching the train to get that
memory a little weird what was I saying
guy remove us in four James Newton
Howard score which is awesome
go to where people are um what that
could mean anything and it's pretty late
at night can you give me a five percent
more helpful suggestion David runs into
the one asshole not wearing black or
gray in this scene and guess what jewel
thief also jewel thief nope not a crime
not going after her fucking date rape no
not stopping that guy in fact everyone
wearing something colorful is a criminal
remember that also David still waiting
for an even worse offender who
conveniently shows up imagine if all he
found from here on out were parking
violators and speeding offenders letting
have to live with having let that rapist
go free can I come in this is an instant
door shutting and locking and calling
the police
but this guy is actually practicing what
his parents taught him always be polite
I sure and then instead of simply
slamming the open door he tries to keep
this guy from opening a screen door oh
it's important for this crazy psycho
killer to wear his orange jumpsuit
wherever he goes even when he's trying
to look like an everyday normal resident
of this house he's really moving about
this house carelessly not remotely
stealthy like he should be he's just
walking slowly but he has no idea where
the bad guy is so he should be sneaking
slowly right water is his only weakness
yet he still somehow chooses to
superhero at a home that has a pool on a
night it's raining also thank God for
the bad guy that David's weakness is
water right otherwise this push off the
balcony is just a minor inconvenience
over a minute and 10 seconds of almost
drowning you moving are we supposed to
believe that after the jumpsuit guy
threw david off the balcony these kids
saw it and were able to save him from
drowning and the orange man didn't see
any of it and the kids aren't freaking
out that they might be seen despite the
night that david is shown to be a
superhero whose only weakness is water
and he can lift 350 pounds of weights
and paint cans this guy will give him a
good fight I just superhero let's also
our marriage is fine now yay you could
argue David sliding the paper into his
son's field of view is his way of
telling Joseph that he was right all
along but I see it a simple bragging
which is selfish
Jesus this is good Sean great Sean what
happened to this guy I mean he does some
things in this movie that are kind of
cheesy and calls attention to himself
but he always gave the story the
characters and the emotional weight a
lot of regard as well I'm removing three
sins for this movie on the whole which
is great and can we get a dam
unbreakable too already
we got two ghost writers here comes the
Whammy ending a pretty good whammy
ending actually but it's kind of hard to
believe David never touched the sky
during all their interactions and got a
sense that Elijah was evil
it's never explained how Elijah planted
a bomb on a plane but I guess nobody
notices guys in all blue suits walking
with a cane in restricted areas like if
there ever was a fire on floors 1 2 or 3
everyone in that hotel will be burned
alive who casually talks about a hotel's
fire safety at a bar who brings up that
the hotel has secrets and the first
thing he says is a fire on the first
three floors would kill everyone welcome
to one of the most anticlimactic endings
especially after dropping a whammy on
you that you'll ever see the movie just
sits here and tells us what happened
rather than showing us even though this
movie is only an hour and 45 minutes
long this ending is almost as terrible
as the entire rest of the movie is
amazing 5 sins for this bull welcome to
hell BH
I love my dead gay son in West
Philadelphia born and raised on the
playground of hammers and most of my
days mr. price can we talk about the
note that you left on my car I'm here to
talk to you about the Avenger initiative
Ezekiel 25:17 the path of the righteous
man is beset on all sides
he's going pro in the draft they say
come on the forty and four point three
seconds thought tommy thomasino sucked
big time also do probation work right
that's right I see violent offenders Oh
bad guys
not necessarily
one of the pin man I think he's one of
them
the garbage man negative